(hip hop beat)
- My American drunk food,
is me making Easy Mac,
put some Honey Nut Cheerios on that,
and a little sriracha.
(laughs)
Bam, that's, drunk food.
(electronic music)
(shrieking)
- What?!
(groans)
- Oh god.
- Okay, sausagey.
- I wanna take a couple
vacation days off work
and take this to Europe with me.
- That's a bug. We're eating a bug.
That's straight-up
Flick from A Bug's Life.
- Chicken
(laughing)
- Listen, this is an origami swan.
- Oh, hell no.
- I can't do it.
- What is this orange ball sack?
- Is that an eyeball?
- It's got a bit of quail.
- I love quail.
- Here's that,
Phillipiines. I finished it.
- Should we do another shot.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Yo, let's be real. This is
from like Iowa or something.
- Oh, fuck yeah.
- I'm guessing there's balls in here.
- These are the best balls
I've ever had in my mouth.
- It's like,
- This is the best thing I've ever eaten.
- Holy fuck.
- I once had a meal from
like a five-star chef.
- Brazil, you got it right.
- What is this shiny food?
- I love,
- And what is this root?
- Oh!
- Oh, what the fuck?
- I like it.
- Uh, that's so salty.
- It's so bad.
- Yo, why are you so nonchalant with this?
- 'Cause, I'm a foody, okay. I like food.
- You need like a full
Big Mac to sober up.
You can't just like
have a piece of salmon.
(laughing)
- Fucking squid.
- Disrespecting Russia, man.
- Oh, it stuck to the wall.
- I regret that. Oh god,
why did you do that?
- This looks like something out of Sbarro.
- That way (chuckling)
- What is it called, a daughter kabob?
- What's donor?
This is really good.
- This is way better than a Big Mac.
- This is a food that's
accessible to the guy
that just came out of the club.
- It's too fancy.
- No, no. Hold on, I'll eat yours.
- No!
- I think these drunk
foods were delicious.
In fact, I think I'm gonna have
a little bit more right now.
- There's not nearly as much
fried stuff as I was expecting.
- Like American drunk food
is good but is limited.
I'm into all your drunk foods.
I loved all the foods.
- Like, if you ever think
about right now if you're
in a coma, and none of this real,
like you're just in a bed somewhere,
with like a little bubuk going.
- I feel weird that the
Internet is watching us eat,
fucking wasted right now!
(laughing)
- I'm gonna throw this at Liz's
face right now. (laughter)